c'est bientôt noël candide et le père
noël rouge où c'est bientôt noël
il faut un prétoire j'aimerais faire
venir en plateau quelqu'un qui adore
enfin une association que j'adore c'est
quelqu'un qui la représentait s'appelle
khadija c'est la président de
l'association soleil d'enfants khadija
viendra
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est ça serait pas sofia et oui c'est
pas sofia khadija ça c'est ça mais chéri
d'amour je voudrais dire vous vous
occupez d'une association qui s'appelle
soleil d'enfants avec tous ces enfants
que j'ai vu toutes les religions
merci d'être là vous faites un travail
exceptionnel vous venez de
montereau-fault-yonne c'est la ville la
plus pauvre de seine-et-marne et khadija
en fait de l'humanitaire depuis l'âge de
saison oui c'est magnifique ce que vous
faites pareil pour sofia tout votre
temps vous le consacre aux autres et g
voilà où on a eu quelqu'un qui nous a
fait une petite vidéo un de six enfants
vous occupez où nous a fait un petit
message regardez ces gars je voudrais
parler d'une association qui s'appelle
soleil d'enfants en france
si une association qui apporte à manger
et des jeux aux enfants et aux familles
dans le besoin et ce serait vachement
bien se couvrir les invités sur ton
plateau
mais voilà on m'a demandé est bâchée
dibar bien sûr qu'on va les invités sur
le plateau
bien sûr elle est la mairie dames ont
regardé ça a été mieux qu'elle dit la
descente combien je vous fait un travail
exceptionnel ce qu on s'est renseigné je
vous le dis avec les équipes de
production et ce soir on voulait
vraiment vous faire plaisir
ça va les enfants c'est être content
d'être là mais ferment cette magnifique
en tout cas qu'est-ce qui attend mon
chéri qu'est ce que tu veux dire qu'est
ce que vous vous êtes fait tous beaucoup
de sacha tu t'es fait tout beau pour moi
pour la télé quoi débattre ossements
t'as pas besoin de te dois être trop
jour beaumont tu t'appelles jibril ça
vous dit oui la sava djib
j'ai fait tout bon aussi j'adore la
coiffure et comment tu t'appelles ça va
bien merci d'être là ça va mehdi a été
vite et bien merci d'être là et grâce à
toi vous êtes tous là ce soir et j'ai
une petite surprise fond vous êtes 15
bénévole dans l'association c'est sain
c'est sain et bon nom de toutes mes
équipes et de ses 8 jeu s'offrent tous
déjà une journée de détente et bien-être
dans un spa parce que vous avez très peu
de temps pour rouler chérie tu as
bizarre je rajoute je rajoute pour vous
tous le truc dont tout le monde rêve
c'est le robot de cuisine ligne [ __ ] pour
régaler la tanit suis là mais ça c'est
trop c'est après dosé pour les quinze
personnes de l'association sa merci
merci merci mais les séries comme c'est
noël je rajoute pour tout le monde
un cadeau de ouf un séjour en europe
chacun un grand merci à la boxe de
wonder merci vous allez partir en leur
tous les bénévoles de l'association qui
vraiment vous passez votre temps à des
enfants câblage à ma chérie ça va skinny
touche réellement c'est que déjà c'est
d'avoir la possibilité de parler de
notre association c'est juste aussi la
possibilité de ramener ses enfants sur
ce plateau ça les touche
ils sont comme des fous est vraiment
enfin nous on est quinze bénévoles on
travaille dans la vie on est tous
bénévoles n'y a pas de salariés dans
l'association
c'est un travail acharné et j'aimerais
rendre hommage à ceux qui travaillent au
quotidien tout le temps après travail et
il y en a qui travaillent à 4 heures du
matin je travaille le week-end et malgré
tout ils donnent de leur force et ça
c'est incroyable comme j'aimerais la
voir tous les quinze un travail
exceptionnel pour les enfants et je
voulais vraiment vous rendre hommage ce
soir et bien sûr déjà je ne suis pas
plus
- déjà avant tout je voudrais au mercy
maufils déjà parce qu'ils m'ont envoyé
un message on me disant merci maman
d'avoir mis ta vie de côté pour les
familles les plus démunies et j'ai envie
de lui dire tout simplement merci à mes
enfants merci à ma famille vous m'avez a
donné cette opportunité de m'occuper
d'eux parce que une famille et surtout
d'avoir mis de côté ma vie
professionnelle pour m'occuper d'eux
c'est moi qui ai envie de dire merci et
c'est pas à eux de me remercier mes
chéris j'aimerais que vous veniez là
parce que pour vous aussi
j'ai bien sûr les petits cadeaux vous
voyez rien buzzer j'aimerais que tous
les enfants vous mettiez votre main sur
le buzzer venez malmenée lundi chéri et
vous allez alors regardez vous allez
regarder là et vous allez appuyer tous
ensemble et vous allez voir ce que je
vous offre ce soir les chéris c'est
parti regardez c'est pour vous c'est
pour nous
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour vous lécher
chercher c'est juste là
aller chercher
free
tous les enfants de l'association
joueurs mercier interne énorme merci à
jean michel lambert le président de
l'association la grande récré pour
l'enfance ils font un travail formidable
pour les enfants hospitalisés au
quotidien je tiens également à remercier
toutes les anciennes solidaire qui nous
ont suivis speedmaster silver li yi et
l'oméga bleus et city geek
voilà pour les enfants iso et c'est là
toute ses marques bravo j'aimerais te
dire que en fait c'est pas une montagne
de jouets qu'on voit c'est des montagnes
de familles qui vont pouvoir fêter noël
et sa merci bon on est très heureux
merci pour ce que tu fais pour eux et
merci pour merci nous avoir accueillis
et franchement je pense juste assez à
ces parents là qui sont dans
l'inquiétude de ne pas pouvoir offrir un
cadeau à leurs enfants et ça c'est dur
qui vont pouvoir le faire donc merci
beaucoup c'est normal et on remercie
toutes les marques qui nous ont suivis
et bien sûr adel qui a fait un travail
magnifique khadija merci d'avoir été là
bas il continué merci à tous la syrie ah
bah merci pour les oies et banias et
baïda mon nom et ben magnifique jeu le
match une grosse soirée sont prochaines
heures
grosse soirée maintenant aujourd'hui
bateau russe avec le confinement une
grosse soirée c'est avec trois personnes
donc je le mettrais merci à tout autre